bonsoir il est 18h si vous venez de nous
rejoindre en direct pour cette nouvelle
édition du 78 lactu le journal de la
rédaction l'heure donc du journal est de
passer à présent au titre à plaisir des
parents d'élèves se mobilisent contre la
probabilité d'une fermeture de classe
dans l'établissement Gérard Philippe ils
évoquent une école surcharger des
enseignements de moins bonne qualité
pendant ce temps 270 élèves de 6e CM2
mais aussi de jeunes étudiants non
voyants de l'Institut National des
Jeunes Aveugles plancher sur le défimat
un travail de logique et de
solidarité complexité du parcours
médico-social interruption du parcours
professionnel difficultés liées au
retour à l'emploi le quotidien des
personnes atteintes par un cancer la
Ligue nationale contre le cancer vient
de livrer les résultats de son enquête
nous en parlerons avec le président du
comité evelinois sur ce plateau tout à
l'heure la nouvelle mobilisation ce
jeudi des personnels de grève des
tribunaux à travers la France c'est
notre image du jour ici à Versailles
c'est dans l'encente de la cours d'appel
à Versailles que s'est déroulé donc un
rassemblement d'une centaine de
personnes parmi les revendications
amélioration des conditions de travail
juste reconnaissance salariale et
recrutement d'urgence vendredi dernier
déjà une action similaire a été menée
elle a permis d'obtenir l'ouverture de
discussions avec Christian tobira des
discussions qui débuteront d'ailleurs
demain au ministère de la justice mais
les syndicats entendent maintenir la
pression la pression également sur
l'inspection académique la possibilité
d'une fermeture de classe dans un
établissement de plaisir inquiète des
parents d'élèves qui se mobilise une
pétition circule depuis maintenant une
semaine les précisions avec ce
reportage dans cette école primaire de
plaisir les parents d'élèves se
mobilisent car ils craignent la
fermeture d'une classe en raison de la
baisse des effectifs l'école primaire
compte une centaine d'enfants il ne
serait plus que 96 à la rentrée
prochaine actuellement cinq classes sont
ouvertes une classe par niveau ce qui
impliquerait en cas de de fermeture un
double niveau est pas acceptable pour
les parents ça pourrait faire un CP CM2
ou CP ce qui serait plus difficile aux
maîtresses de faire différents
niveaux s'occuper du d'une moitié de la
classe et de l'autre aussi à côté les
élèves devront être beaucoup plus
autonomes ce ce qui n'est pas tous les
jours facile déjà avec avec une une
classe normale sans sans double niveau
on aurait des classes tout de suite de
presque 20 25 26 si c'est pas 30 élèves
des fois une pétition circule depuis une
semaine 11 signatures ont été
recueillies une mobilisation qui
intervient alors que se tenait ce jeudi
à l'inspection académique des ivelines
le conseil technique spécial
départemental chargé notamment de la
présentation de la future carte
scolaire on parle à présent en santé
dans cette édition du 78 du jeudi 10
avril et bonsoir à vous docteur mailleur
bienvenue sur ce plateau vous êtes le
président du comité yvelinois de la
Ligue contre le cancer cet après-midi
présentation du bilan du dispositif d'
d'observation pour l'action sociale et
vous pointez du doigt les difficultés au
quotidien pour les personnes atteintes
du cancer dans la société au travail on
va en parler mais déjà nous avons voulu
savoir si l'opinion publique avait
conscience de ce problème c'est notre
question du jour les malades du cancer
sont-ils à l'écart de la société selon
vous non mon mari est soigné en ce
moment et il n'a pas non il y a pas de
discrimination c'est une maladie comme
une autre oui pourquoi parce que dès que
l'employeur le sait il s'arrange pour
les dans un placard où il est licencié
normalement c'est inadmissible il faut
les soulager il faut les soutenir pour
moi il y a pas de discrimination ils
sont ils sont plus protégés que qu'autre
chose pour moi bah j'espère pas sinon on
naappellererait pas ça la famille des
amis enfin je pense he oui enfin on
c'est quelque chose qu'on entend souvent
dans les médias mais personnellement je
sais pas par rapport au travail à
l'embauche par exemple ou à une
progression dans le travail par rapport
à des prêts aussi je pense on va réagir
à ce micro trottoir tout le monde n'a
pas conscience de cette discrimination
pourtant elle est bien réelle envers les
personnes qui sont atteintes par le
cancer on a entendu tout de même
certaines personnes parler du travail
c'est peut-être là où ça se retrouve le
plus quand l'employeur le sait on est
licencié en tout cas mis à l'écart oui
ça devient une vraie difficulté c'est
vrai qu'on on progresse dans les
traitements on a d'énormes avancées
maintenant il faut aussi se préoccuper
de l'aprèscancer fait partie d'ailleurs
des points des points relevés par le le
3isème plan
cancer mais dans le quotidien on voit
bien que nos patients sont confrontés à
des difficultés de maintien dans
l'emploi de retour à l'emploi qui sont
considérables et les témoignages des
patients sont tous les mêmes on a un
regard qui change le patient a un regard
qui change vis-à-vis de son travail mais
l'employeur et l'environnement
professionnel change de regard vis-à-vis
de l'exptient complexité complexité du
parcours médico-social interruption du
parcours professionnel difficultés lié
au retour à l'emploi c'est ce qui
ressort dans les grandes lignes du
dispositif d'observation pour l'action
sociale qui a été présenté cet
après-midi quelles sont les difficultés
les les plus fréquentes en dehors du
travail en dehors du travail il y a une
première difficulté qui n'est plus
l'accès aux soins mais le reste à charge
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait les gens sont
pris en charge à 100 % certes mais il
existe des choses qui restent à charge
de du du malade ou de son entourage qui
peuvent conduire d'ailleurs dans
certains cas à des refus de soins en
partie ou à euh euh de l'endettement ou
des des conséquences quand même assez
importantes c'est la deuxième fois que
ce rapport est mené mais c'est la
première fois que le département des
ivelines participe pourquoi cette
implication cette année et puis est-ce
que vous attendiez un petit peu à ce
genre de de réponse aussi j'imagine que
le département n'est pas épargné par
rapport aux autres alors pourquoi on y
participe c'est la deuxème campagne et
c'était un un sujet qui travaillait si
j'ose dire le comité déjà depuis un
certain temps et donc ça nous nous a
paru tout à fait naturel de d'engager
nos forces dans cette action les
résultats evlinois sont un peu
différents par certains point de des du
reste du territoire l'enquête a été
faite dans si je me souviens bien 12
départements pour le moment c'est pas
encore l'échelle nationale il y a eu
plus de 2000 personnes quand même qui
ont participé 2000 patients qui ont qui
ont répondu voilà on a un peu plus de
cadres par exemple qui ont qui ont
participer un peu plus de gens qui
étaient encore dans le travail voilà des
petites différences parce que c'était
volontaire hein si on vient sur la
méthode ologie un petit peu ce sont les
gens qui souhaitaient participer qui
souhaitaent témoigner on leur renvoyait
on leur proposait de remplir le
questionnaire et c'était à eux donc soit
dans les centres de soins soit les
assistantes sociales enfin il y a plein
de manières différentes d'obtenir le
questionnaire et c'est le patient qui
remplit le questionnaire de manière
anonyme et qu'il renvoyait au comité
comment se fait-il qu'il n'y ait pas eu
peut-être plus d'anticipation sur ces
questions d'accompagnement en tout cas
de ces personnes atteintes par par la
maladie du cancer c'est parce que
jusqu'à présent on s'est focalisé sur la
guérison la recherche la médecine alors
certainement parce que il fallait déjà
arriver à commencer à avoir des
résultats quand même on commence
vraiment à avoir des résultats
thérapeutiques qui s'améliorent
considérablement même si on
malheureusement on ne guérit pas encore
tout le monde mais on a des vrais
percés dans dans notre domaine et on a
de plus en plus de patients qui
justement sont des survivants ce qui
n'existait peut-être moins quand même
certainement même moins quand j'ai
commencé la cancérologie il y a un peu
plus de 20 ans et donc l'accompagnement
de nos patients la remontée et la lig
contre le cancer est la première AC
association je dirais en France de
lobbying de patients on l'a vu depuis
les années la fin des années 90 fait
remonter tous ces problèmes qui
deviennent émergents et récurrents
vraiment récurrents on va écouter un
témoignage à présent recueiller cet
après-midi lorsque vous avez présenté ce
dispositif les résultats en tout cas à
la presse voici le témoignage d'une
personne qui a eu justement des
difficultés au quotidien en raison de
cette
maladie on a l'impression d'être de se
retrouver seul de désociabilisé en plus
je me suis retrouvé arrêté début juillet
donc au moment de la période de vacances
il y avait plus personne autour de moi
en septembre vous revenez pas travailler
à l'âge que j'avais je sais que j'ai des
collègues qui ont pensa que j'étais en
congé matité c'est pas grave
bon ça c'est la première chose la
seconde c'est la difficulté à évaluer le
moment où vous allez être capable de
retourner travailler on accompagne ces
personnes aujourd'hui il y a des
dispositifs pour les accompagner comme
cette dame qu'on vient d'entendre on
essaye on essaye mais là on tombe euh
dans une espèce de millefeuilles
administratives c'est peut-être un terme
à la mode mais il y a une complexité des
acteurs qui est phénoménal alors le
cancérologue lui mais c'est pas son son
cœur de métier euh bien sûr il essaie
d'encourager et d'accompagner les
patients euh vers le le problème du
retour à l'emploi entre autres euh on
essaie de les accompagner vers euh
l'assistante sociale et cetera mais même
les assistantes sociales cet après-midi
ont témoigné elles-mêmes de la
complexité du problème puisque
l'interlocuteur auprès de la CAE
d'assurance maladie auprès de tel
organisme et cetera peut varier et
cetera on tombe sur des plateaux
téléphoniques de temps en temps enfin
des choses qui sont du vécu mais qui
rendent le parcours extrêmement complexe
maintenant que le problème a été posé
que les difficultés ont été analysées
avec ce deuxième rapport et on le disait
pour la première fois le département y a
participé est-ce qu'il y a des pistes
des solutions à présent qui sont
envisagé alors des des des pistes
d'abord c'est quand même il est quand
même notable de voir que dans le trè
plan cancer voilà le retour à l'emploi
ce ce type de de lutte contre les
inégalités sont pointés et donc on
espère avoir des actions qui vont qui
qui qui vont se mettre en place avec
quel moyens on verra quels sont les
moyens
nécessaires il y a certainement un
travail de simplification administrative
à faire ça ça me paraît évident puis on
peut imaginer des solutions
intéressantes une de Cell que qu'on
pourrait pronner par exemple ce serait
l'arrivée de consultation de médecine du
travail non pas au sein des entreprises
mais de les délocaliser par exemple pour
un certain nombre dans les centres de
soins pour avoir une meilleure
coordination et les patients souvent
nous disent aussi une chose mais j'ai
peur d'en parler à mon médecin du
travail parce que tout de suite il va
dire à l'employeur le médecin du travail
il est tenu au secret professionnel
comme tout le monde et à chaque fois que
j'ai eu des contacts par exemple avec un
médecin de travail pour un cas
particulier ça a toujours été facilitant
peut-être une parenthèse sur l'aspect
financier aussi parce que ce sont des
difficultés que rencontre ces personnes
même après quand il faut se se réinsérer
dans le dans le monde professionnel on
peut c'est un accompagnement spécifique
aussi ça fait partie des des choses qui
sont étudiées en tout cas que vous
soulevez et que vous amenez pouvoir
public oui euh alors on est quand même
dans le problème de d'une enveloppe
fermée donc pour le budget de la
Sécurité sociale donc il y a un moment
où il faut faire des choix donc on ne
pourra pas à mon avis continuer à tout
prendre en charge voilà très
vraisemblablement maintenant il faut
sélectionner on a des des vrais soucis
de de reste à charge et des choses qui
devrait vraiment à mon sens être prise
en charge je citais tout à l'heure lors
de cette réunion le problème des
prothèses dentaires on a des traitements
qui peuvent abîmer effectivement les
dents la bouche et cetera et ces
prothèses dentaires ne sont pas
correctement prises en charge donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait soit on fait pas le
traitement ou alors il y a des
complications particulièrement
intéressantes ou alors on retire les
dents et ça s'arrête là et comment on
fait le patient pour manger après donc
il y a pas il y a pas de logique en tout
cas dans le dans dans les soins et les
conséquen a une logique dans les soins
oui mais dans la suite Quié il y a des
progrès à faire dans la prise en charge
du reste à charge voilà on parlait des
des malades est-ce que cette cette
enquête que vous avez mené se penche
aussi sur le quotidien de l'entourage
des malades de toutes ces personnes qui
accompagnent et qui elles aussi ont
parfois besoin d'être guidé pour savoir
réagir aussi alors l'enquête si on n pas
développé directement ça mais il est
très clair que
l'impact est majeur sur le patient mais
sur tous les proches voilà on a les
proches qui s'arrêtent de travailler qui
aménagent leur travail voilà tout tous
des pistes pour pouvoir aider le patient
et donc là aussi il y a des réflexions à
voir dans l'avenir pour voir comment
comment est-ce qu'on peut les aider mais
il faudrait aussi avoir des dispositifs
uniformisant les les aides un exemple on
a des tas d'aides pour les personnes
âgées mais vous êtes jeune vous avez un
cancer vous avez des enfants ça va mal
vous avez des complications enfin peu
importe la situation et bien si sous
prétexte que vous êtes jeune et ben là
il y a pas d'aide pour vous pour vous
aider à la maison c'est extrêmement
compliqué on voit ces différentes
conclusion hein qui amène forcément
maintenant des réponses parce qu'elles
sont forcément attendues par les
personnes qui sont concernées une
dernière question est-ce qu'il encore
une une enquête qui sera menée l'année
prochaine est-ce que vous P les les tous
les de ans à priori oui et puis on va
élargir à plus de départements sur le
plan national encore vous aurai
l'occasion de venir nous nous en parler
on l' espère avec des résultats plus
meilleurs encage en tout cas merci
Docteur ma d'être venu sur ce plateau
président du comité éelinois de la Ligue
contre le cancer la semaine du handicap
à en cours qui vient de s'achever
c'était dimanche dernier une
démonstration de handb qui était
proposée vous allez le voir le Vélo Club
DL encour 550 ans en Yveline via sa
structure hand disport permettait aux
personnes en situation de handicap de
participer à des activités sportives de
découvertees une animation difficile une
ambition difficile pardon à mettre en
pratique les vélos ont été importés des
États-Unis ils ont subi plusieurs
modifications tout cela coûte très cher
et l'encour se revendique aujourd'hui
comme le premier club en Europe à faire
du handbike tout chemin on écoute le
vice-président du club et l'un des
adhérents au situation de handicap les
journé d'aujourd'hui ça nous permet de
faire découvrir le handicap fa voir que
le handicap c'est pas forcément un
obstacle pour nous les obstacles il y en
a pas de permettre de faire voir que les
handicapés faire faire du sport
et trouver des solutions d'évasion et de
faire voir que donc la journée
d'aujourd'hui c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment génial pour nous en plus il
fait beau c'est super pour tous les gens
qui qui qui on qui connaissent un
handicap moteur des membres inférieurs
bah c'est vrai que c'est c'est c'est
super comme comme discipline ça ça
entretient ça fait travailler le
cœur c'est puis c'est agréable tout
simplement on parle de l'économie à
présent c'est dans les hautes scènes que
Manoel a choisi de faire sa première
sortie en tant que Premier ministre ce
jeudi matin il était donc dans les
locaux de Talès communication et
sécurité à l'occasion de la Semaine de
l'Industrie Thalès qui justement dans le
cadre de cette semaine a ouvert ses
différents locaux à travers la France
dont ce desiveline a des étudiants
retour sur les échanges entre les
ingénieurs et les étudiants c'était en
début de semaine à Chatou cler Cambier
et le dioine on a besoin de plus en plus
d'électricité donc on on repense toutes
les architectures électriques et ici on
travaille chez taes beaucoup sur le
l'avion du futur les architectures
électriques lundi ses élèves de BTS ont
quitté leur salle de cours pour visiter
une entreprise spécialisé dans les
systèmes électriques embarqués des
avions une visite organisée dans le
cadre de la Semaine de l'Industrie un
événement nationale pour faire découvrir
ce secteur au grand public mais surtout
aux jeunes Stéphane gugin a accepté
d'expliquer l'activité de son entreprise
un moyen pour lui de partager sa passion
très jeune j'ai connu une vocation pour
la technique vraiment
un amour de de la science et donc besoin
aussi de toucher des choses concrètes et
voilà je me suis lancé donc dans une
formation d'ingénieur et puis j'ai très
vite intégré Talès cela fait maintenant
15 ans qu'il travaille au sein du groupe
les étudiants sont familiarisés avec le
secteur mais pour beaucoup c'est la
première fois qu'il visite une si grosse
structure c'est beaucoup plus
impressionnant je me dis on ne voyait
pas comme ça à grande échelle là on se
dit d'accord il va falloir peut-être
bosser un peu plus que ça qu' on voit à
l'école et là c'est pas pareil c'est
voilà c'est un notre niveau matthéou
s'est enchanté pour talè le Paris est
gagné car pour le leader européen de
l'électronique de vol ce type
d'événement est un moyen de susciter des
vocations on a recruté beaucoup l'année
dernière on a recruté plus de 100
personnes sur la
sociétées on recrute des ingénieurs des
techniciens et donc ce qui nous
intéresse justement c'est de communiquer
sur nos métier au-delà du site le groupe
prévoit de recruter 1000 collaborateurs
cette année de l'économie aux
mathématiques à Chevreuse un professeur
de mathématique a lancé un grand défi à
ses élèves pendant 1hure et3 CM2 et 6e
ont tenté de résoudre énigm et problèmes
géométriques de quoi voir les maths
différemment Anthony re et lodim moine
se sont essayés à quelques
exercices calculer la somme des 100
premiers nombres entiers c'est à ce
genre de question que par groupe de 4
250 élèves ont planché pendant 1h et dem
sur des énigmes mathématiques ou des
problèmes de géométrie lors du Défi mat
cétait plus trouver des chiffres des
nombres des choses comme ça et c'était
facile difficile cétait plutôt difficile
il y en a tro qu'on n pas fait ces
élèves de CM2 et de 6e doivent également
surmonter le multitest partie de calcul
mental et de logique encadré par des
collégiens de 3e faisant office de jure
et si les exercices sont conçus pour des
enfants pas si facile de les résoudre
même pour les autres professeurs c'est
pas simple et il semblerait que les
enfants s'en sortent mieux que nous on a
cherché les rbuts et même les rbut là
bon c'est pas simple créé en 2008 l'idée
de ce concours est aussi d'effacer la
réputation difficile des mathématiques
des cours et des contrôles c'est
histoire de voir les les mathématiques
différemment donc autrement parce que
bon c'est vrai que les mathématique
c'est une matière souvent qui fait peur
on en a une mauvaise image alors qu'en
réalité vous avez bien
les élèves ils étaient 300 ils se sont
éclatés ils se sont abusés en parallèle
13 collégiens non voyant de l'Institut
National des Jeunes Aveugles
participaient au défi pour sensibiliser
leurs camarades au
handicap depuis 20 ans les
établissements scolaires se mobilisent
pour l'association
là à travers l'opération met basket et
bat la maladie à l'école ce meri c'était
au tour du collège Darius Milot de
Sartrouville sous le parinage de la
championne de tennis mar B de s'engager
Antony ils sont rassemblés devant la
ligne de départ pour redonner de
l'espoir un sourire à Benoît 22 ans
atteint de la
locystrophie le concept est simple après
avoir collecté des dons les 300 élèves
de ce collège yvelinois CHUS leur basket
et bouc un circuit à leur rythme ça fait
plaisir ça fait Chud au cur et super
content à chaque fois qu'on dit qu'on va
aller voir les enfants il a un sourire
donc ça c'est déjà bien pour les
encourager l'ancienne joueuse de tennis
Marion Bartoli donne le départ une
présence naturelle pour la vainqueur du
tournoi de Wimbledon
2013 j'avais un enfant de ma classe en
fait qui avait malheureusement cette
maladie et c'est vrai que voilà on
essayait nous de de l'intégrer vraiment
complètement dans la classe même si
parfois c'était c'était difficile
certaines choses mais pas le laisser à
part pas le pas qu'il se sente en fait
rjeté et et justement aussi de les voir
tous ses enfants les voir en présence de
Benoît aujourd'hui de voir qu'ils sont
assez ces côté finalement je trouve que
le lien est très fort après avoir été
sensibilisé à la maladie les élèves de
6e ont récolté 4000 € au profit de la
recherche et de l'accompagnement des
familles pris en charge par
l'association et là c'est un moment de
solidarité et un moment de partage voilà
donc on quitte nos habits de professeur
traditionnels et on vient pour
effectivement bah cette belle cause qui
est la l'association est là essayer de
sensibiliser les élèves un peu à tout ça
depuis
1994 l'opération met basket et B à
maladie à l'école a permis de récolter
23 millions
d'euros pour un nouveau point complet
sur l'actualité local rendez-vous demain
même heure il sera question notamment de
l'élection attendue à la tête du
département de Pierre Bédier écarté en
2009 de la présidence en raison d'une
condamnation judiciaire il a maintenant
purgé sa peine il est revenu il y a
quelques mois en tant que conseiller
général Alain Schmid UMP également a
aujourd'hui démission et Pierre Bédier
devrait reprendre donc la présidence ce
sera demain vendredi matin et nous en
parlerons bien évidemment dans le 78
lactu d'ici là excellente soirée votre
soirée sur TVfil c'est avec Claire
Cambier pour filch le magazine
hebdomadaire de
l'économie